[Música]
ah
primeramente buenas noches mi nombre es
andrés quiroz soy estudiante de
ingeniería mecatrónica y hoy les voy a
explicar un poco del concepto de mi
título si lo vemos a simple vista puede
que no lleguemos a una conclusión
acertada puede que nos vayamos más hacia
el lado humano al lado tecnológico puede
que pensemos en un sabor pero al final
creo que no vamos a entender a primera
vista es por eso que les voy a contar mi
historia
y entonces comenzamos con una frase mi
título es una pregunta o es una
afirmación ustedes se consideran humanos
artificiales o están en el camino de
serlo pues en el trasfondo podemos
nosotros intentar pensar en lo que somos
pero podemos decir que somos buenas
personas malas personas pero el término
artificial no nos va a dar nada claro es
por eso que yo comencé con esta pregunta
cuando tenía 7 años
aquí podemos ver un claro ejemplo
expectativa versus realidad el de la
derecha soy yo ya podemos ver un niño
ahí con todos sus juguetes y estaba
jugando con mi perro y mirada creo que
estaba semidesnudo pero ya estaba
entonces creo que en ese momento
tenía un problema qué problema tren que
tengo yo a los 7 años o sea no voy a
pensar en la paz mundial no voy a pensar
en el hambre de al otro lado del mundo
el único problema que tenía en ese
momento era que quería jugar pero no
había dinero
mi familia estaba atravesando por una
situación difícil económicamente y algo
que bien recuerdo hasta este momento es
que dicen que las necesidades la madre
de todas las invenciones bien creo que
ha sido la necesidad ha hecho que yo y
no bien haciendo juegos y demás cosas
ya entonces nace esta pregunta por
ejemplo mi mamá en esos momentos hacía
todo para ganar dinero podríamos decir
que recolectado en botellas envases de
plástico de shampoo botellas de cerveza
botellas de visser bencina y todo lo que
se pueda reunir para que se pueda vender
aunque sea por 2 bolivianos 5 bolivianos
porque nos hacía falta es así que un día
yo veo me voy a un rincón de mi casa y
veo tapitas tiradas y yo digo
qué puedo hacer con esto entonces de un
momento a otro ya no eran tapitas eran
ya andinas y las botellas ya no eran
botellas eran chasis de autos o de botes
entonces es ahí que nace la combinación
de ambas de mi necesidad con las
botellas y es ahí que nace una sinergia
con el transcurrir de los años podemos
decir que ya las tapitas no no me
satisfacía era como que ya había hecho
todo lo que se puede hacer en plástico y
había hecho aviones y había hecho
autitos ya había hecho casitas y ha
visto muñecos y había hecho robots todo
lo que quieran en plástico pero cuando
vas creciendo quieres más y yo ya ya no
podía ser más es así que mi papá un día
de esos me ve y me dice hijo mañana te
quiero ver seis de la mañana parado y no
me preguntes por qué grande y ya para
entonces yo estaba parado ahí bien
abrigaditos y de un momento a otro
aparecido en la 16 de julio
y es que no era muy frecuente que mi
papá me saqué mi papá era se refiere
entonces salió a las 4 de la mañana y
volvía a las 12 entonces el lapso de
tiempo en el que compartimos momentos
era muy corto entonces cuando llegamos
mi sorpresa era de que en todo lugar en
todo en todas partes del suelo había en
partes y yo me imaginaba lo que iba a
hacer con ellas y la posibilidad era
infinita es así que de un momento a otro
mi papá me dice ya toma esta caja me lo
compra una cajita me ha hecho calza todo
lo que quieras y al final nos vamos ir
con estudiosa de en serio en serio y
está esos momentos y el precio de todos
los componentes electrónicos no era muy
caro porque ahora sí van está un precio
elevado porque ya están escogidos pero
en ese momento yo era de esto yo quiero
esto yo quiero esto yo quiero esto yo
quiero y al final tenía una caja llena
de cosas que al llegar a mi casa
he empezado a trabajar
y ahí nace la verdadera sinergia de
encontrar cosas de la basura
transformarlas en juguetes pero faltaba
algo no creen digamos de qué
de que
simplemente era un juego que como creo
que la mayoría de las personas hasta
ahora pensamos porque no era hasta ese
entonces que yo comencé a salir con mis
motorcitos iba a la carnicería con
motorcitos iba al colegio con motorcito
salían a la iglesia con mi mamá con
motorcitos entonces llegado el momento
alguien tenía que preguntarme qué estás
haciendo con ese motorcito si puedes
llevar la pregunta y era la de mi
maestra me dijo qué estás haciendo con
esos motorcito si no era pues una
pregunta de mira está trabajando con
algo que interesante no era porque
distraía todos los alumnos y no le
tomaban a tres de una atención ella y
ella me dijo sabes en vez de estarás
haciendo me distraerá media clase creo
que debería ser mejor que apliques estas
cosas y nos ayudes y yo decía cómo puedo
ayudar a mi profesor sean algún motor
sólo gira y pues ahí conocí los leds
entonces les parecerá algo un poco
simple pero a los 7 años que te
enciendan un led que forme un número que
sumes con leche es la cosa más
maravillosa porque contacté el que
brilló con tal de que se mueva un niño
se va quedando mirándote y con el paso
del tiempo ya fui desarrollando más me
conocí
pero no tanto a profundidad ya sin ya
que simplemente era un juego y mi mayor
acercamiento con la educación
simplemente fue realizar estos leds
cambia de colegio e ingresé al colegio
la salle sin mérito ni gloria pase los
años pero algo me cambió cuando estaba
en la promoción por cosas de la vida me
animé entrar a las olimpiadas de
computación y de un momento a otro pues
ya sabía programar y imagínense o sea ya
sabía en conectar les ya saber programar
y entonces boom que es andrés hizo un
guante pero este guante que resolvían
como les había comentado mi papá en ese
momento era cerrajero entonces ahí le
decían pájaro por alguna razón bueno las
razones que se subía los techos sin
arnés entonces de un momento a otro
podían volar
si no no no hagan eso seriamente
y entonces de un momento a otro el
pájaro ha caído al suelo y se ha
lastimado del brazo yo entonces cuando
estaba en casa le molestado a mi mamá
adela cambio al canal y ella iba a de la
encender el ventilador entonces como
estaba en medio y mi mamá renegado es
decir ya no voy a hacer voz mover ideas
con la otra mano de otra mano está mal
pero no no no es seguía porque al final
de cuentas que pierdas tu mano derecha
es un impedimento bastante grande cuando
eres trabajador entonces él ya entró en
una etapa de depresión como quiera ya no
puedo hacer nada estoy perdiendo
trabajos y yo no podía verlo pues asia
se me era bastante raro verlo en casa
cuando les dije no hay que salir a las 4
de la mañana volví a las 12 de la noche
y sólo aparecía dinero en la mesa era
como que está haciendo mi papá él no es
así
él es trabajador entonces yo dije este
programa debería ayudarlo y de un
momento a otro creo que le brindó una
solución y es este guante
con este guante podría realizar digamos
que con un movimiento leve podría
cambiar de canal con apuntando al
ventilador podía encenderlo apuntaba a
su foco y de la misma manera podía pagar
entonces verán la cara de sorpresa de mi
papá care hijo entonces esto el primero
era de susto no era de que funcionaba
sin hombre esto me va a quemar la mano o
sea me había ganado la fama de hacer
cortocircuitos en colegio porque de un
momento a otro dejé sin luz en mi curso
y poesía desde ese momento andrés no
toques enchufes
y entonces creo que eso duró
aproximadamente una semana
hasta que mi papá se festejará ya no se
sabe que los mayores en algún momento
sacan excusas para festejar y llegó
borrar y que creen que ha pasado con el
one
estaba roto y ha llegado hijo no es roto
cibir mal
pero en ese momento ya no ha sido una
frase que he dicho no te preocupes papá
sí lo he hecho una vez no voy a volver a
hacer diez veces y es ahí que pues
comenzó la idea de comenzar a realizar
todas estas cosas para ayudar a las
personas pero obviamente no tenía
todavía los conocimientos suficientes
estaba en colegio tenían la necesidad de
aprobar no era como que me encontraba en
una etapa donde tenía la posibilidad de
hacer mis estudios y dedicarme a otra
cosa porque todavía en este punto no
tenía un rumbo definido estaba entre
estudiar ingeniería mecatrónica o
directamente medicina llama y pues ya
estaba llegando al final del año como
que todo pasó de forma normal tranquila
llegó el día de mi graduación
es ahí donde pues mi papá me acompaña a
subir
yo estaba en referís porque mi papá me
estaba acompañando de que no aparecía en
casa y el que sólo traía dinero entonces
el qué
el que me dio todo estaba acompañando y
pues tan grande fue su alegría que se
fue a festejar después de acabar
lo triste de esta historia es que no
regresó
fue a festejar y de un momento a otro él
se cayó cayó seis metros no sé si vi que
en la entrada del túnel de la calle
potosí
y ustedes se preguntarán el pájaro
muertas el ratón no el aguantado ha
estado tres días vivo pero ya yo no
había solución entonces creo que ha sido
un punto de quiebre totalmente fuerte
para mí y no era el primero porque a la
edad de los diez años perdí a mi hermano
de la misma manera
entonces era como que las personas que
me habían enseñado que me envían ha
ayudado a crecer estaban perdiéndose y
yo no podía dejar que eso pase de alguna
u otra manera debía de hacer que sus
conocimientos perduran
puedo citar lo que decía mi hermano no
basta con ser un buen profesional que
digamos se hace el mayor de cadó del
mundo que tengas las mejores notas
porque al final si no eres una buena
persona eso no te va a llevar a ningún
lado ninguno le va a contratar vas a
estar sin trabajo y vas a tener tus
miles de títulos
y ya
es ahí que de un momento a otro no sabía
qué hacer con mi vida y dicen que cuando
uno quiere algo con todo el corazón se
va a cumplir y es así que entré a la
católica no sé de como no sabemos hasta
ahora cómo está pasando pero es ahí que
nace mi primer voluntariado si ustedes
bajan por aquí por españa' de
informaciones van a encontrar distintos
tipos de letrero y no sé si alguna vez
se han puesto a leerlos o se han tomado
la molestia de decir qué es esto porque
está ocupando espacio no sé qué están
haciendo porque se toman la molestia de
colocarlo y no en uno de esos decía
voluntariado y pues se me ocurrió la
idea de entrar yo no sabía nada de los
voluntariados lo más cercano que había
tenido era
ayudar a ancianos en el asilo san ramón
que era algo obligatorio de mi colegio y
bueno casualmente había sido un
voluntariado para niños con síndrome de
dominó
creo que ese fue un momento donde se me
partió el corazón porque conocí a un
niño llamado el niño porque mire de este
tamaño y tiene 27 años entonces creo que
la primera impresión que tendría usted
sería de ser que tiene 27 años y sí sí
tenía 27 tenía dificultades del habla
psicomotrices y de comunicación
obviamente entonces es ahí que nace eso
mi examen es un proyecto que ha
participado en el space apps de la nasa
ha sido ganador de una nominación
especial también para su transición de
30 segundos para que se ha enviado el
vídeo exsome es un exoesqueleto que
permite que tu presencia se transmita a
otro lugar sin los riesgos que conlleva
estar en este lugar digamos tú podrías
estar en la luna simulando que estás con
el exoesqueleto aquí
o sea la idea original era esa pero como
la picasa a los niños con el pasar de
los años se lleva a una conclusión mi
alegría ya no estaba en que mis cosas
funcionen a la primera sino en que se
haya una verdadera utilidad una utilidad
real que las personas apliquen
y pasó otro año y yo ya me pregunte
ahora qué voy a hacer si nos fijamos en
todas las ocasiones y qué podemos hacer
de borrachos y asia de sanos tratamos de
culpar al gobierno tratamos de decir el
gobierno no nos da educación el gobierno
no nos da esto el gobierno nos da otra
cosa pero no se aparte de nosotros lo
que tenemos que hacer es ahí que decido
meterme al tema de la educación
ya se acuerdan de los leds esta vez vino
con una ruina y ahora si tienes
no es solamente conectarlos as podemos
aquí observar digamos lo más simple un
juego de dados pero ya después comienza
el diseño la planificación la
distribución de sistemas y de modelos
para robótica educativa tenemos a mínimo
tenemos smart que todos estos los
seguirá distribuyendo en distintos
centros educativos a bajo costo pero
ustedes dirán para que ustedes dirán que
las robóticas sólo es para genios es
para alguien que le gustan las
matemáticas sino no es así en un robot
para las distintas áreas estén digamos
desde la ciencia de la matemática el
arte la educación la ingeniería entonces
cualquier persona puede dedicarse a la
robótica hacerse parte de ella es así
que comenzamos con inglés química
matemáticas física y entonces será una
educación integral gracias a estos
robots
y bueno ahora nos preguntamos si todo
esto para que que logramos dando un poco
de nosotros a otras personas
no sé si pueden ver las caras de estas
personas que están ahí agarradas en una
cosa en especial a estos niños que están
aquí tratando de jugar con un juego en
realidad aumentada
realmente lo que me genera satisfacción
en este momento es pensar que todo lo
que yo estoy haciendo es para un bien
común en donde otras personas salen
beneficiadas
creo que sea parte de las charlas terex
es contar experiencias pero no creo que
sería mejor que lo demostremos en este
momento
ella es una alumna de la de peta es un
centro de inclusión para las personas
sordas ella me ayudó a hacer un último
dispositivo que consiste en traducir el
lenguaje de señas a voz y d y viceversa
de voz a señas en este momento ella
tiene un mensaje que decirles
hola mi nombre es luis para las personas
sordas
es difícil ver la tele porque todo es
obra ahora puedo decir lo que pienso y
que ustedes oyentes me entiendan y no
saben la alegría que me da poder hacerlo
como
la aplicación puede haber muchas obras
que fueren ayudan a darnos la
oportunidad de ser mejores y podré
lograr mis sueños y metas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
como este hay muchos ejemplos que puedo
citar pero creo que nos hemos alejado un
poco del tema de mi charla que es un
humano artificial un humano artificial
es aquella persona que pese a tener sus
logros al tope no se preocupa por los
que están a su alrededor como en un
equipo de fútbol messi será el mejor
jugador del mundo pero al final de
cuentas si no tiene un equipo no puede
avanzar es lo que pasa con nosotros si
no mejoramos nuestro país por más de que
tengas 20 títulos por más de que seas el
mejor de la clase si no avanzamos como
sociedad va a llegar un punto donde te
vas a estancar es ahí que con esto les
quiero demostrar que puede existir una
sinergia entre su vocación y la
posibilidad de ayudar a las personas y
que dentro de ello se existe la
verdadera felicidad
y la razón por la que estoy animado y
motivada de hacer una charla télex es
porque de un momento a otro esta frase
me cambió la vida dice que el sentido de
la vida es darle sentido a tu vida y qué
mejor manera de hacerlo que ayudando a
las personas gracias
[Aplausos]